(dramatic instrumental music)
- There's always like
limits you have to respect,
and whatever, especially
in the Middle East.
You can't be completely free.
When I vogue, it's like
I'm expressing myself fully
without no restrictions whatsoever.
So I can just be me.
I have a mini-zoo at
home; they're my babies.
I'm studying veterinary medicine,
but I also have, like,
this artistic side of me.
I'm the voguing fabulous
vet, let's say that.
Beirut is really so crazy 'cause there's
a lot of cultures going there,
a lot of politics, religions.
There's specific places in
Beirut, which are accepting,
but there's other places
in Beirut where you cannot
be who you are, you might get attacked.
I try not to think of
that 'cause, you know,
it's just too problematic and I don't
have time for that to be honest.
I'm too busy building my life and
my career to think about politics.
Politics is bullshit
to me, I don't like it.
Let's talk about voguing, honey.
Let's talk about it.
(laughs)
(slow electronic music)
Voguing is a dance style that was created
by the LGBTQ people of color back
in the '80s in New York City.
It was created as a safe
space for these people
to be themselves and express themselves
without being judged by other people.
It's all sad, just like
practicing at home,
having fun and just learning over YouTube,
'cause you know there's no
voguers in Lebanon whatsoever.
So practicing every single day
for like three hours in
my room or anywhere I can,
I would just practice everyday.
And then I start posting
videos on social media,
and I started growing bigger and bigger.
I think it's something very me, and I love
to teach it to people, and I would love
to spread this culture to other people
'cause it's a beautiful culture.
On Friday, I'm having a performance
in a club called Projekt.
So Projekt is like the
most accepting LGBTQ club,
so, yeah, everyone goes there
just to have fun and be free.
I've been preparing with my dancers
and their outfits and everything.
So I'm panicking; I'm always panicking.
This club is fully crowded
every Friday, you have no idea.
And you have like
hundreds of people there,
so it's gonna be a big show,
it's gonna be really amazing.
People do not like feminine stuff,
especially like presumptive gay people.
They would prefer masculine
people 'cause their kind
of discreet and they think,
like, being feminine is
just having fun and
being silly or whatever.
Voguing's such a culture,
which is very queer.
It's not straight at all, it's
not masculine as a culture.
It means a lot of hard work and
to show people it's something fun.
Once you're like fully dressed
with the makeup and everything,
it's just who you are.
It feels so great, you feel like,
oh, this is my moment to shine.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Dancing is ultimate freedom, it is life.
(audience cheering and applause)
(slow electronic music)
Once I'm dancing, I'm charging
myself again to face the world.
To me, it's not a problem being queer
or being different than anyone else.
I'm just me, and, take it or leave it.